do you think I am this stumped to lose
all the rating to get highlighted I was
frustrated you guys top it all you close
my account
shouldn't you be fired from your job
because I think you are with your reels
and then and you also murder someone oh
my God you want to take that one I feel
like I probably should because I was
personally called out Hello World
International Master Danny wrench back
again Chief chess officer of chess.com
now joined by International Master Casa
Corley he is just.com's head of
community and one of the main things
that he does in that role is actually
work pretty closely with me and a lot of
the other fair play heads to uh what is
it exactly that we do in trying to catch
cheaters Casa yeah look um the game of
chess is online and you know we're in a
position where we have more players than
ever competing for more prize money than
ever so we essentially have to protect
and ensure the Integrity of the game and
so what we a lot of the work we do is
just making sure that games are played
uh cleanly that you know we have you
know events with High Caliber games and
that the people that win stuff deserve
what they get so that's pretty much the
dynamic and we deal with a lot of people
who get pretty pissed off when we catch
them for cheating and on that note Casa
and I are about to read some messages we
have never seen before you know the
drill you've seen these videos you love
them it's time to react to your messages
uh meaning you the community and uh
let's Jump Right In I was playing and I
felt I was doing like a grand master and
then I got suspended and closed well
one of the one of the things we've
learned Casa is if you're not actually a
grand master
you probably can't play like a grand
master that's usually a thing we've
learned your thoughts let me put it like
this
chess is the one game or sport where you
really actually have to put in some reps
before you get there you know what I
mean they're these prodigies in
basketball they just sort of pick it up
after a year and they're just fire that
doesn't happen in chess so you know this
kind of doing it like a grand master
like there's no like Mike uh path to
success here you got to put in the work
or just turtle and stockfish and then
get close for cheating right so there
you go to the other
hi I'm a chess player since six years
old I play drunk driving or distracted
but I am not a bad player or cheater
first of all I hope you're not playing
chess while drunk and driving or playing
chess while driving or honestly none of
those things go together and
um none of our algorithms have anything
to do with whether you were doing those
things you were just cheating man the
crazy thing is it almost seems to
suggest that you know he's playing
better under these circumstances and
like hence the data you know like uh I.E
this is why the success is what it is
well actually that also just not how it
works so
um you know I mean respect to you
playing well
um under adversarial circumstances but
it seems like you are playing a little
too well under these circumstances
I love it first and foremost I would
like to emphasize that my intention
behind cheating was not to gain an
unfair Advantage for personal gain but
rather to raise awareness about the
detrimental effects of cheating in chess
that we actually see a version of this
um at times where folks are like I'm
gonna be the the renaissance man or
woman to essentially cheat and help us
improve our systems don't do that we uh
we did a great job of uh of auditing our
own processes and you know ultimately
there's no there's no glory and
martyrdom here so uh you know if you if
you see something say something and we
will uh we take feedback very well as a
company so but but don't do that
what what Casa said next question I did
not cheat in any way according to the
guild lean's Gotham chess used to spot
cheaters I do not follow any of them my
account is over two months old my time
usage was less than a second per move in
my games where my account was closed wow
so wait is Levy giving tips on how to
not get caught for cheating if so we
need to talk to Levy about that but also
I don't think that those were very good
tips nothing about what we're doing has
to do with how long your accounts been
opened and if you're making stockfish
best move in less than a second that
that that's gonna raise a red flag or
two
wantedmychess.com to match with my life
s rating and when it didn't match I felt
very bad about Miss left
I gave us the assist Lee chess we have
to dunk on it I mean it's just the truth
lead chest ratings are are inflated and
in this case it actually is making
people feel bad so leechas please work
on the uh please work on the inflation
yeah you know something Honesty will get
you far in life so you know this was you
made a mistake here and you know there's
a path back uh uh there's a there's path
back on our site and there's a path back
in many places in life so I appreciate
the honesty um do better
I love the advice from Casa I paid
Samone to get up my rating in chess
sorry it was Dumb and foolish well again
as Casa said honesty can go a long way
in life and it's nice to admit that you
made a foolish decision both to pay
someone
to inflate your rating you lost some
money and then also you got caught for
cheating so any other thoughts chess is
not just about the Cosmetics here you
know it's basically what you did is you
you basically put on a bunch of makeup
you got someone else to misrepresent
yourself and at some point you're also
going to have to play so you know do you
want to really be someone that you're
not or for such a long indefinite period
of time or do you want to actually just
be who you are so because frankly as
soon as you know this pay-to-play scheme
goes away you know the rating is just
gonna go like this and how are you going
to feel about that so in addition to
just doing the wrong thing policy wise
on our site like it the long term play I
don't even see it can I give a shout out
to the friend for running that Ponzi
scheme because it's a lot easier for
people to cheat for free with stockfish
whoever that friend is convincing people
to pay him to improve their I mean shout
out to you man
um entrepreneur I love playing chess but
my strength bans my fifth time in
chess.com but in LA chess still hasn't
BTW I'm 3 3.1 K in life s
wow
wow that stings a little bit
um if you're if you're if your lead
chest is cheat detection team I don't
know how to deal with that first of all
it stings us a little bit how has this
guy gotten five chances let's find the
IP address and close them out at this
point
yeah 100 uh that definitely we're not
giving out multiple chances uh at
chess.com so I I mean maybe he
misrepresented uh his experience a
little bit but yeah again
um you know we are a site that wants to
you know have fair and Equitable play
and so you know if you're you're not if
you're trying to do the most go
somewhere else I got a mail from one of
those in your company names where he
accused me of cheating and sandbagging
can you please elaborate where was I
gonna cheat with the lower rating can
you please tell me which tournament I
was going to participate with a rating
of
1600. can you guys please analyze my
chess games can you tell me I am a
cheater you piece of
do you think I am this stumped to lose
all the rating to get highlighted I was
frustrated you guys top it all you close
my account
because shouldn't you be fired from your
job because I think you are with your
reels and then and you also murder
someone oh my God you want to take that
one
I feel like I probably should because I
was personally called out I mean wow uh
sandbagging is also wrong it is also
wrong and there are tournaments where
people win prizes because they drop
their rating and then they move up the
ladder so respectfully and great choice
of words even with the personal attack I
gotta be honest that was great and you
made me laugh and they say laughing
keeps you young so thank you thank you
good sir
sometimes in life you know you you need
to use discretion and this maybe was one
of those times where you know the words
you you put on the the page were not
ideal that being said
you know again
sandbagging is a form of cheating you
know there are there are class prizes
all over the board and online that we
disperse to people that earn them and
it's a huge part of Chess development to
win class prize and feel good about uh
playing against people around your level
and when you sandbag Are you purposely
lower your raising ready to get a prod
in some way you sour the experience of a
lot of other people so we just can't
have that I used outside assistance
because to impress a chick
hmm well first of all
impressing a lady friend not sure how
she wants to be referred to is the
reason people have done a lot of things
for a lot of years I would say that
cheating at chess though might have the
reverse effect because she might be like
hey you're not capable of doing it
yourself but I also I'm not going to
continue to elaborate because I don't
know anything about your relationship I
gossip I'm lost on this one yeah like is
this like a budding relationship is this
one that's been like this is like six
months three months one date it's really
tough to say
um you know that being said there
there's so many better ways to uh to uh
draw uh impress others and you know I
mean really you I think more so than
impressing other people you really want
people to just respect you and I don't
respect people that cheat and I don't
think she would either
I was frustrated losing and wouldn't
have done it if I would have three
Diamond membership and would be
motivated to play fair
wow that's black that's like
blackmailing us
saying like if you just given me a
diamond membership I wouldn't have
cheated on your site I mean honestly
probably checks out if we had given him
a diamond membership he wouldn't have
cheated but
um I don't know that there's that that's
the right way to rectify this or that uh
as I once read an eye for an eye leaves
the world blind so you can't ask for
things in return because of bad things
you did you can't be looking for Revenge
man there was a real Scooby-Doo Arc
there I don't know if you caught that
yeah I would have gotten away with it
too if I if it was if I got a diamond
membership you know
I would have done something totally
reasonable if I got my diamond I only
use engine while playing with friends
the amount of messages confessions we've
had of this nature over the years may
not surprise you right it is actually a
pretty common case but we don't know
that you're only using it with your
friends there actually is if you let us
know ahead of time of a game you want to
have with a partner where you're both
gonna do that we actually are normally
okay with it as long as you let us know
but that just that's just you telling us
that we did our job we did a good job
yeah and again I think a lot of people
do use engines to train like I mean um I
mean they don't usually use it to play
but they do use it to train and so you
know
under the right circumstances and you
know if you apply the right prophylaxis
we might be amenable to that but you
know you can't just you know do that and
then retroactively complain so yeah yeah
I only cheated to be first in the league
and get a free membership I don't have
enough money to afford one I've always
played Fair before can you pass my email
to Daniel wrench he's a really nice guy
he may gift me this membership
first of all I have a really nice guy
and I you know what as long as you
confess to cheating I will gift you a
membership economic hardships can befall
anyone and uh you know personally I was
someone that you know didn't have the
money to just be like going out getting
to coaching and all this other stuff so
I totally understand not having the
means to get where you want to go but
it's always going to feel a lot better
when you do it the right way and this
isn't the right way and so you know
Danny might be you know uh nice enough
as you say to you know work something
out here but um but yeah you know that's
not the right way
I'm not condoning what you did either
that was wrong because you also cheated
other people out of being first in the
league that said
appreciate the honesty you gotta dive in
membership coming your way I convinced a
pretty girl I could play chess but I
could not tried to be smart to use an
engine and it sort of worked out
turned out I started to like chess more
than the girl and would happily make
fair use of chess.com again to play and
develop my skills fairly I love that
story arc you know like you you know the
the girl was like maybe got caught up in
the chest craze and she was like ah
these these chess players are kind of
cool and then he was like I want to be
one of those chess players and then uh
man like that that Evolution was awesome
so
um you know minus the cheating part you
know yeah like there's there's ways to
get better at the game we have a ton of
resources on our site to get better at
the game check out some of those you
know like it's you know there wasn't
there was no need to change your way to
that to that promise also this is this
is a tale as old of time we've seen it
in Hollywood movies for years right guy
wants girl Guy cheats to get girl guy
gets girl guy dumps girl for chess and
you know that's it right everywhere this
happens all the time and so uh I don't
want to say wait to go but I am glad
you're into chess and let's play fairly
all right well that's gonna do it for us
another fair play reading messages from
the community concept this was your
first time but I think I think we're
gonna have you back uh you might be a
natural at responding to these messages
off the cuff
a pleasure I mean at the end of the day
it's one of it's one of my favorite
things is just getting as close to the
people as possible and just hearing from
folks that are using our site even
unethically is interesting so uh
appreciate it
said it so we love you no matter what as
long as you're using our site preferably
ethically and uh if you enjoyed this
check out some of the other videos in
our series here you can see those links
click on them we're having a lot of fun
engaging with you the community and
until next time we will see you around
on chess.com